heavily vaxxed areas are overwhelmed by
oh
macron but few people are dying and yet
everyone is panicking i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you're trying to help
out your holiday budget this season
you're spending a lot of money on
christmas gifts now's a great time to
save on stuff you don't need to be
spending a lot of money on and that
would mean your cell phone bill if you'd
like to be a hero for the holidays how
about getting your loved one a new
iphone as well that's right puretalk has
iphone 12s starting at just 479 bucks
through the end of the year and yes they
have the 13s too i switched to peertalk
i'm getting the same great nationwide 5g
coverage as the big guys you can as well
the average family will save over 800
dollars a year just by switching over
it's a lot of money i wouldn't tell you
to use a service i'm not completely
happy with you should make the switch
with puretalk's 30-day risk-free
guarantee you have nothing to lose
unlimited talk text six gigs of data
just 30 bucks a month and as i said you
get the iphone 12 right now for 479 it's
a great deal go to puretalk.com shop for
the plan and phone that is right for you
enter promo code shapiro save an
additional 50 off your very first month
and save on a new phone that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless some
restrictions apply see site for details
that's puretalk.com promo code shapiro
to get started and save an additional 50
off your very first month of coverage
alrighty so
we're all supposed to panic right panic
panic everybody panic okay this is the
tenor in the media today the entire
media are now under the impression that
we are all going to die of covid now
this is not a change from the entire
history of the pandemic at the beginning
we were all going to die of covered but
we didn't know anything then we knew
that if you were young and healthy the
chances were very very low that you were
going to die of covid it didn't matter
the media continued to proclaim that you
were going to die of covid because covid
was super duper duper scary no matter
the fact that if you were young you had
about 1 000 times less a chance of dying
than if you were elderly in the united
states or that if you were obese you got
a far higher chance of dying than if you
were healthy
there are very obvious striations in
terms of risk when it came to covet from
the very start and the media just fibbed
about it they would have on doctors
they'd have one fouchy or they'd have on
or they'd have on robert redfeld they'd
have on people who would just say things
like well you know you could die and say
well that doesn't help me at all i need
an actual risk assessment it's true any
possible day i could die any moment i
could die right lightning bolt comes
down from the sky hits you and you're
dead that could happen but nobody lives
their life in fear of the lightning bolt
so the question is whether we are
talking about a lightning bolt coming
down from the sky or whether we are
talking about the chances that you're
gonna get hit by a car or whether we're
going to die of cancer over the course
of your lifetime so what exactly are the
chances here and the media continually
refuse to assess the risk well now
they're doing the exact same thing with
oh macron right omicron is supposed to
be the scariest thing ever and the
reason that omicron is super scary is
because it is evading vaccines when it
comes to
preventing infection
and because it is really really
transmissible and so everybody's going
to get it now your first question should
be when somebody says you are about to
get hit with a virus your first question
should be okay how bad is it going to be
that would be the normal first question
right you're going to get hit with a
virus i want to know whether the virus
is ebola or whether the virus is the
common cold which one is it and if
somebody told you you are going to get
the common cold this year live in fear
you'd be like uh no
no i'm gonna be fine i probably won't
even stay home from the office i'm just
gonna take a little dayquil and go into
the office because it turns out that
even if i give it to everybody else in
the office and they all get the common
cold then whatever man because that's
life now we can't all live in a society
together without some people getting
mild illness sometimes right that's just
a normal fact of everyday life we've
forgotten about all that the media have
decided that any time there is a mild
illness that everybody is going to get
we are supposed to freak the we're
supposed to freak out
so you see headlines like this coveted
surge is gripping new york city ahead of
the holidays we've never seen this
before alexandra marquez writing for
cnbc.com
new york city's cover 19 positivity rate
doubled in just three days as the city
battles a virus surge ahead of the
holidays
dr j varma a top health advisor to mayor
bill de blasio tweeted thursday um we've
never seen this before in new york city
from december 9th to december 12th the
percentage of positive tests in the city
spiked from 3.9 percent to 7.8 percent
varma said this is sars covet 2 evading
both vaccine and virus-induced immunity
against infection unlike any variant
before now notice he's not saying that
it is evading vaccine or virus induced
immunity
against hospitalization and death which
is the thing you actually care about
again if i were going to tell you
that
you already had coveted that means that
if you get coveted again you're not
gonna die you're not gonna be
hospitalized you're gonna be sick for
like a day is that good okay well you
know that's life
but the way that they they constantly
conflate in the media
immunity against infection versus
immunity against hospitalization and
death i don't care about being infected
with the virus if it means that i have
the sniffles i don't care and no one
else should care because that is just
called life
we're supposed to care now because we
have been trained by the media and by
our government that the government can
stop this thing again i keep saying it
because it's true there's a fundamental
lie we were told from day one and that's
if you listen to the government enough
the virus will just go away it will just
stop that is not correct it is not true
it has never been true it is certainly
not true now
which means that we're going to have to
live with the virus
good news the virus you have to live
with now is so much milder than the
original variant that it is in most
cases asymptomatic or common cold like
according to the according to the latest
data and yet we're supposed to treat it
as though it's going to kill everybody
for purposes of telling you to mask up
and lock down and even if you're
backstreet you're supposed to stay away
from people like all of this is nonsense
i'm just telling you it's nonsense
like the the measures that are being
recommended right now by your public
health establishment are completely
disconnected from the conditions on the
ground they're completely disconnected
from the data on omicron they're
completely disconnected they've been
disconnected for a while okay they were
disconnected once the vaccines came out
and then they were disconnected with
regard to delta we still okay still
there are zero studies zero showing that
any mass short of a k n 95 stops delta
forget about omicron omicron by the way
is 70 times more infectious than delta
we still don't have a study that study
from malaysia one that they're
constantly citing about how effective
masks are and there are serious
questions about that study in the first
place i looked at that study there it is
not a particularly well constructed
study
even if you take the bottom line results
at face value that was a test that was
done before the rise of delta i asked
the study authors myself
i mean we are seeing this thing spread
like nobody's business
and guess what
people are generally not dying
that's what the data are showing
but again the media have to push this
thing like it's the end of the world
positivity rates are rising says cnbc as
the omicron variant spreads according to
data released wednesday from the centers
for disease control and prevention new
york and new jersey are the two states
with the most rapid spread of the newly
identified variant okay by the way this
should show you that all of the
governments talk about how lockdown
measures are going to save us all uh you
notice two of the most locked down
states still are new jersey and new york
in the country they're also two of the
states with the highest vaccination
rates so um what happened
what happened we were told that if we
did all of the things it would you would
protect us
weird because they did all the things in
new york they did all the things in new
jersey and guess what it's real cold
outside so everybody's going inside and
they're all getting infected with the
virus
just as i said they would
because that's what the data show see
all along the line here i have just been
following the data the actual underlying
data that's what i care about i don't
care about the politics of masking i
don't care about the politics of
lockdowns i don't care about any of the
politics of it because it's irrelevant
the question is going to be how you
balance the everyday needs of americans
with the risk factors from the virus
and all balances were deemed verboten
from day one by the media and by the
government if you said we have to
balance these two factors how you live
your life and the risks of the virus
they would say no no you have to treat
the risks of the virus
not only
as completely outsized like wildly out
of proportion with what the actual risks
of the virus are you have to completely
disregard any other associated costs
and if you don't do that you're a bad
person if you don't do that you want to
kill grandma
this was the line and they're still
using that same line and somehow idiots
are falling for it it's amazing to me
somehow people are still falling for
this thing
listen if you are elderly you should be
scared of of pretty much
anything that is disease related
it was funny i was at dinner last night
with an ophthalmologist friend
and uh is a really large practice and he
was talking he gave me a statistic i
found fascinating the dirty little
secret about medicine in the united
states is that the people in the united
states who die are old
now i know that's a shock to you but
that is the reality whenever you hear
that something kills a lot of americans
understand that virtually everything we
are talking about is a thing that kills
a lot of old americans because it turns
out as you get older you get closer to
death
i know statistical it's shocking it's
shocking
how dare we mention the fact that as you
get older you are probably going to die
at a higher rate
than if you are 30.
i know this is devastating news
to all of us who know this from the time
that we are small children
that if you die at night your chances of
dying at 91 are not the same as your
chance of dying at 11 right like we all
know this but when we mention it it's
kind of awkward okay so here's the stat
you ready for this what is the surgery
with the highest associated rate of
death the surgery in the united states
after which people tend to die most
often
what do you think it is
the answer cataract surgery
now cataract surgery is like an
outpatient procedure where very often
you don't even have to be anesthetized a
cataract surgery is
not a major procedure
so why is everybody dying after a
cataract surgery why do so many people
die after because they're all 90 that's
why you have cataracts in the first
place
you have cataracts in the first place
because you're 90. and then you die
because you're 90 not because of the
cataract okay so this is true with
virtually everything in american life we
talked about this a few days ago there's
a big headline in the new york times one
out of 100 people who are above the age
of 65 in the united states died of covet
last year
they're like right but how many people
above the age of 65
die every year in the united states and
the answer is four
and one out of 25 people above the age
of 65 will die in the united states why
because there are a lot of people above
the age of 65 who are 80.
there are a lot of people above the age
of 65 who are 90.
so yeah that is not a shocking statistic
particularly the reason this makes a
difference folks is because when you are
constructing systems for the entirety of
humanity when you're constructing
systems that don't just affect 80 year
olds in nursing homes but affect 30 year
olds at work or five-year-olds at school
and you don't treat them differently
it's because you are doing bad public
policy it's because you're an ignoramus
or you're badly motivated those are the
only two possibilities here it is
certainly not driven by public health
but they're gonna panic you is the only
way that they can control you
according to dr dave a chucksey
commissioner of the new york city health
department oh macron is here in new york
city it is spreading quickly de blasio
and his health advisors at the briefing
expressed concern ahead of the holiday
season demand for testing has increased
following a few major events including
last weekend's annual santa con pub
crawl event he said we're seeing a surge
ahead of the holidays i do expect cases
will continue to increase in the coming
days
de blasio announced that they're going
to increase their testing good luck i
mean i'm sorry but the testing you can't
test and trace it ain't going to make a
difference this thing spreads too fast
right now in south korea they can't slow
down covet 19. more than 80 of south
korea is is dosed already two doses
but they're now reinstituting
restrictions based on omicron see here
is the thing it's an it's an amazing
logical flip that they've made okay the
idea is in order to prevent forever
lockdown we must lock you down
indefinitely you see the trick
the trick is we have to lock you down
now without an end date
so that you won't have to lock down
forever
i feel like that's kind of the same
thing guys i kind of because you have
offered no pathway out you have like at
what point do you say we're done
the answer is at no point do you say
we're done ever ever ever ever because
i'm looking at the stats right now okay
here is the way usually coveted works
the way covert works is usually have a
spike in cases then about two weeks
later or a week later you have a spike
in hospitalization and then about three
weeks later
or to a month later you have a spike in
death so i'm looking at the south
african stats right now okay south
africa
started to spike in terms of cases
basically mid-november so they went from
their seven-day
running average of cases
being essentially 245 275 somewhere in
that neighborhood at the beginning of
november and then in in you know mid mid
to late november about a month ago it
spiked it started to spike it went up to
687 new cases per day and then you had 8
000 new cases per day by the end of
november and today you have about 25 000
new cases per day in south africa right
so started a spike at the end of
december i mean at the end at the end of
november
at the end of november mid-november
about a month ago this is when we
started to see the spike in cases so you
would expect to see a
spike in death as well correct
uh there is only one problem i'm also
looking at the south african death
statistics and i'm seeing no spike in
death as in zero none zip nada no
okay the the average rolling death rate
in november mid-november was about 15.
the average rolling death rate seven day
rolling death rate right now is about
27.
so no
the answer is no
right the seven day average november
10th was 31. the average rolling death
rate today 29
which means omicron and by the way this
is not a secret this is the part that's
unbelievable it's not a secret the south
african scientists said this at the time
the people who discovered the variant we
played clips of them on the show talking
about how this thing was basically
manifesting as a cold or
asymptomatically and yet we're going to
go crazy anyway
and we're going to design public policy
that is not rooted in anything remotely
resembling reality we'll get to more on
this in just a second it's absolutely
maddening it's absolutely maddening
first
it is the holidays you deserve a gift a
gift that is going to keep on giving all
year long i'm talking about a gift that
looks as good as it feels and it's going
to pay for itself in terms of how much
more productive you will be at work
this is the gift of the x chair
manufactured by god's own angels to make
you as comfortable as possible i'm
talking about a chair that can cool you
down i'm talking about a chair that can
heat your back i'm talking about a
massage chair and all of it while you
sit flat on your butt doing your work
right this is the magic of the x-chair
it is the world's greatest office chair
again it descended directly from the
angel raphael
made it in his workshop brought it down
to earth now is the perfect time to
purchase an extra buy early and buy now
and here is x chairs holiday gift to you
save 100 off your ex chair just by
purchasing it at exchairshapiro.com
right now that's the letter x chair
shapiro.com extra has a 30-day guarantee
of complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month go to extra shapiro.com save
xchairshapiro.com go check it out right
now get your own little slice of sitting
heaven ex
chairshapiro.com alrighty so
it's not it's spreading really really
fast
here's what we know it's spreading super
fast according to the hill a new study
says that while the coven-19 omicron
variant infects the human body 70 times
faster than previous coronavirus strains
the infections appear to be less severe
researchers from the university of hong
kong's lks faculty of medicine found
that after 24 hours of infection the
omicron variant multiplied in the human
bronchus 70 times faster than the delta
variant and the original coronavirus
strain that means basically in your
throat
they also discovered that the omicron
infection in the lungs was significantly
lower than the initial cova-19 strain
okay well that would be the thing right
if you look at my wife was showing me
x-rays of this the other day
what a typical
delta or original variant covered
patient with severe covet ends up
looking like and the lungs are pretty
heavily damaged right you can see
the cloudiness of the lungs
because this is a respiratory ailment
when people die of covet it's because
they're having respiratory problems okay
well if it's not affecting the lungs who
cares you have like a mild cough you
have like a cold
the strain replicated in human lung
tissue at a rate that was more than 10
times lower than the original coven-19
strain which suggests it may cause less
severe illness
okay so here's what we know super
infectious gonna be almost impossible to
stop people from getting it because it
is resistant to
to the vaccines in terms of infection
according to a study authored by more
than 20 scientists at columbia and
university of hong kong a striking
feature of the variance is the large
number of spike mutations that pose a
threat to the efficacy of current
covenant 19 vaccines in antibody
therapies because the way that the
vaccines were constructed is they were
constructed to target spike proteins to
resist
infection right but
this particular mutation has evolved to
become less deadly but more infectious
which is very often how these viruses
work right if you're a virus and i
understand viruses don't have brains but
if you are you are thinking in sort of
the richard dawkins selfish gene notion
if these viruses are attempting to
replicate then the goal would not be to
kill the host you'd be to get the host
to infect as many human beings as
possible so that means that viruses tend
to become more infectious and less
deadly over time
so this would not be a giant shock okay
so what it did is it mutated to
target a bunch of spike proteins so the
ones that were resistant are now being
avoided
okay so it could greatly compromise the
vaccine in terms of the infection but
remember that's not all the vaccines do
the vaccines don't just target the spike
protein to prevent infection they also
generated an immune response this is
what vaccines are meant to do they
generate an immune response that is then
understood by the body you get t cell
immunity and b cell immunity you get
memory cell immunity so the body knows
how to fight it now
basically vaccines do a couple of things
to prevent infection they target these
spike proteins that that are that are
that can prevent the infection but they
also train the body so the body
remembers how to fight the infection
once the infection occurs it's basically
like a dojo for your body's immune
system okay so this is what we've seen
we've seen that pfizer for example
the resistance rate to infection for two
doses has dropped to like 33
for people with omicron so you're
probably gonna get infected even if you
have two doses but
it also means that the resilience
against hospitalization and death
remains incredibly high
right there is a um
there's an article over at medpage today
talking about the early data
with regard to oh macron and and how
exactly the the vaccines are responding
to it two dose series performs well in
real world analysis from south africa's
largest health insurer
an analysis by insured discovery health
from the first three weeks of the
omicron wave showed 70
protection against hospitalization for
those who received the two-dose series
compared with the unvaccinated though
that's a decline from the 93 protection
scene during delta it's still regarded
as very good protection according to the
report which was published in a press
release on the company's website
protection against hospitalization was
maintained across all people aged 18 to
their slightly lower level of protection
for those aged 60 to 69 about 67 and 70
to 79 59 according to data shared during
the briefing
overall protection against infection
fell to 33 so what does that mean it
means that there's a good shot that even
if you're double dosed even if you're
triple dosed that you will get infected
but the chances that you're gonna die
are really low and the reason they're
low is because number one the disease
itself is now less deadly and number two
because you have retained prior immunity
against actual hospitalization and death
which is the thing we used to care about
by the way some
monoclonal antibodies are still working
regeneron not so much but it turns out
regeneron said that it might not be as
effective against the new variant but
data confirms it has diminished potency
but that's not true for astrazeneca so
astrazeneca said that their coronavirus
and body cocktail was retaining
neutralizing activity against domicron
and we'll get new data i'm sure very
soon as to whether the fisa pill will
still apply against domicrum but again
omicron is likely not going to kill you
because most cases are like a severe
cold
i'm going to bring you that data in just
one second again data data data make
your decisions based on data don't make
your decisions based on what
politicians and lying members of the
media
interpret the data as we'll get to that
in one second first
if you run a company you know that you
didn't want to spend you didn't found
your company because you want to spend
time doing hr okay hr is like the toby
in the office is how everybody thinks of
hr but here's the thing without toby
your company could completely collapse
in on itself like a dying star yeah
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations hr
manager salaries are not cheap they're
an average of 70 000 bucks a year bambi
is spelled b-a-m-b-e-e it was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy maintain your compliance all for
just 99 bucks a month with bambi you can
change hr from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day-to-day all
for just 99 bucks a month they're month
to month no hidden fees you can cancel
any time you didn't start your business
because you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance let bambi help get your free
hr audit today go to bambi.com shapiro
bam to the bee.com shapiro schedule your
free hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro it's spelled at b a m to the b e
e dot com
shapiro to get started today okay so
how mild is the virus according to
professor tim spector most cases now
appear like a severe cold omicron
appears to produce a fairly mild illness
he's the chief scientist on the zoe app
which is a major study that treks
attracts coveted symptoms he says the
majority of infected people no longer
have the classical triad of persistent
cough fever and loss of smell and taste
he says his team has yet to gather
complete data on omicron symptoms but
initial findings suggest they are not
much different from delta which already
showed milder and more cold-like
symptoms than previous variants as well
so what should you look for sneezing
headache runny nose or throat etc
yeah but but the media again
they continue to cover this as though
it's the end of the world
and they're using the uncertainty as the
lever for power here
right yeah sure it looks like the data
are that omicron isn't gonna kill like a
lot of people in terms of infection
fatality right
but we don't know
but we don't so as out of an abundance
of caution never live life again just
shut everything down
take measures that clearly are not going
to stop omicron so that you have made
your sacrifice to the pagan gods just do
it and then you'll feel better about
yourself you'll feel like you've done
everything you could do
okay now this is this is craziness it
really really is
so here's here's the deal the cdc is
suggesting that 18 500 people could be
dying per week the reason that they are
suggesting this is because
the thing is so infectious
so according to the daily mail grim new
figures from the centers for disease
control and prevention have predicted
that us covet 19 deaths will soar by 73
percent to 15 600 a week by january 8.
cases will rocket to 1.3 million a week
by christmas day the agency revealed its
projections on wednesday afternoon that
show america will suffer up to 15 600
new coveted deaths a week as of january
8th or 2 200 deaths per day a 58
increase from 8 900 deaths currently
being recorded each week which is
equivalent to about 1285 deaths per day
so why
the answer is because every single human
will get omicron
okay so here's the question what you're
going to do
really what are you going to do
because what we were talking about
there's
people don't understand
base rates they really don't so
infection fatality rate means your
chances of dying if you are infected the
infection fatality rate
on omicron appears to be significantly
lower than delta we had already lowered
the infection fatality rate on delta for
the vaccinated dramatically but omicron
appears to be way lower than that
which means that your chances if you get
omicron of dying or being hospitalized
are extraordinarily low but if every
human being on planet earth gets omicron
an absolute number of people who die
will be higher
those people will generally be immune
uncompromised or old
okay that that's just the reality of the
situation
now what you're going to do about it so
what they have decided is that they're
going to tell you to mask up and never
see another human being again
there's
there's only one problem with that which
is that the data don't back that
you can ask everybody
really you can ask everybody on earth
and unless they're wearing n95s you know
very very strong particle filters
the chance is that it's going to stop
omicron which again is 70 times as
infectious as delta and delta was not
even tested with regard to surgical
masks
i'm not seeing the data to back this i'm
not
and i'm frankly kind of puzzled by by
the strategy here
by the way in order to before omicron
because there's a study out by aaron
prosser bartosz helfer and david shriner
in med rx
okay which is the pre-print server for
health sciences
they tried to analyze the number of
unvaccinated people who would need to be
excluded to prevent sars coveted two
transmissions right for vaccine
passports this is before omicron which
is way more infectious
like so much more infectious that
huge parties of people who are already
vaccinated are getting it
okay and triple that are getting it so
this study suggests this is before
remember before omicron which is way
more infectious in order to prevent one
infection you would need to exclude 1
000 unvaccinated people
quote our study suggests that at least
one thousand unvaccinated people likely
need to be excluded to prevent one sars
coveted two transmission event in most
types of setting for most jurisdictions
notably australia california canada
china france israel and
others so you'd have to exclude 1 000
humans who are unvaccinated to prevent
one transmission now
what do you do with a variant that is
way more infectious than delta
like really are lockdowns likely to work
and once again let me point out that if
you are young you are your chance of
dying from omicron if you're young are
my newt by the way even during the
pandemic during the pandemic itself like
the worst of the pandemic if you were 18
to 49 you are now more likely to die of
fentanyl overdose than you were to die
of covid
this is according to fox 10 phoenix
families against fentanyl released some
stats they show that between 2020 and
2021 nearly 79 000 people between 18 and
45 died of fentanyl overdoses
the number of people who died of covet
19 between those ages
between the dates january 1 2020 and
december 15 2021 was 53 000. so not only
did more people die of fentanyl overdose
between 18 and 45 during that date it
was like 50 percent more people died of
fentanyl overdose
out of the 800 000 americans who have
died of
of covet 19
this means of the 800 000 people
the grand total number of people under
the age of 46 who have died of covid
is about 54 000
right that which
again it is heavily striated toward the
elderly because death is heavily
striated toward the elderly
but instead of figuring out okay what do
we need to do to theoretically protect
the elderly more instead they're still
trying to push lockdowns here's joe
biden's spokeswoman yesterday
karine jean-pierre not saying we can't
rule out more lockdowns of course you
can't because you kind of want them
you've you've made a box and now you
can't get out of it you suggested you're
going to end covet you certainly cannot
end omicron and uh and yet you have to
maintain the myth
as it relates to shutdowns which is what
i was trying to convey uh to uh jeff as
he asked me this question look you know
we've been very clear dr fauci has been
very clear um
our public health experts have been very
clear we know what works and we're going
to continue to do what works which is
making sure that you know we do
everything we can to get folks
vaccinated we're at 71 of people being
fully vaccinated that's a huge
difference to where we were a year ago
as i just stated a year ago we were at
less than one percent
okay but um i've noticed that it's
spiking in places where people are
vaccinated so what exactly is your goal
if your goal is to prevent
hospitalization and death i agree people
should vaccinate i've been saying this
all the way throughout the pandemic that
as soon as the vaccines were available i
thought that people should get the
vaccines
however
now you're talking about taking measures
that are not likely to prevent
transmission you're not going to end all
of this so what are you going to do
what are you gonna do according to the
new york times breakthrough infections
are common this week denmark reported
that three-quarters three-quarters of
omicron cases occurred in people who had
received two vaccine doses
a recent outbreak at cornell
may have been driven by omicron 97 of
the population at cornell is vaccinated
so um
what exactly is your plan
seriously what's your plan because i've
been saying for a long time that when it
comes to covid everyone now has had the
opportunity to get the vaccine
that's all you can do
end of story the fact that more people
are going to get omicron does not change
that
in fact theoretically omicron is is a
better thing to get than delta
i mean if you as an individual not
unlike a broad nationwide plane because
more cases lead to more absolute deaths
but on an individual level your personal
chances of dying from omicron are
apparently significantly lower than your
personal chances of dying of delta so if
you're going to get one of these
diseases anyway you may as well get
omicron you're going to have to
you're going to get one of them pickle
them across sort of the so that's not a
bad thing that's a good thing omicron
replacing delta on a broad statistical
level is a is a good thing if
everybody's going to end up with delta
anyway
nonetheless joe biden continues to push
the idea that it's boosters and boosters
and and the unvaccinated who are the
true risk again the unvaccinated were at
risk from from covid
depending on your age it was either a
high risk if you were elderly or a
fairly low risk if you were 20.
the unvaccinated were and and they are
currently at the exact same risk maybe a
lower risk now if you're unvaccinated
because again if you're unvaccinated and
you get omicron it's way milder
so maybe you are at like a way lower
risk than you were with delta
so in other words omicron replacing
delta
if you were if you were like driven to
get a vaccine like driven driven driven
not sorry if you were driven not to get
a vaccine like you really didn't want to
get a vaccine and the reason that you
didn't want to get a vaccine is not
because you were afraid of infection but
you felt like the infection was going to
be less
problematic for you than the vaccine and
this is why you didn't get the vaccine
or you felt that you already had covid
and that means you have t-cell and
b-cell immunity
if that was your logic omicron not only
does not change your logic it
exacerbates your logic
because if you're one of the people who
didn't get the vaccine because you were
afraid that the vaccine was more severe
than delta
and omicron is less severe than delta by
the transitive property you should now
be less afraid of not getting the
vaccine than you were before
the only reason that you were interested
in getting the vaccine was to
evade the the consequences of the
disease if omicron is less deadly than
delta
then the math on why you should get a
vaccine is actually worse not better
right this is
again so so the logic has not changed
for the people who are unvaccinated
which is part of the problem again like
if you want to get vaccinated you should
get vaccinated if you don't want to get
vaccinated you know i may think you're
wrong but you have that right in the
united states but joe biden is going to
continue to push this he says the
unvaccinated are looking at a winter of
severe disease and death i have a
question
weren't they looking at that winter
anyway with delta
and why exactly are like he's pushing
vax mandates
i don't know how you push a vacant
mandate on the back of omicron that
isn't going to work with regard to delta
this is why by the way you know you
should go sign our petition at
dailywire.com do not comply it's our
petition against the vax mandates from
the biden administration we of course
were the first company in america to
file a lawsuit against the vaccine
mandates when they came down we're over
900 000 signatures at this point we're
aiming for a million by christmas so
please help us out forward it to all of
your friends anyway here's joe biden
blaming the unvaccinated for everything
even though the vaccinated are passing
this as well
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospital they'll soon overwhelm
but
there's good news if you're vaccinated
you have your booster shot you're
protected from severe illness and death
okay um so he's gonna focus on bax
mandates at this point
based on omicron if it didn't work with
delta it ain't going to work with
omicron omicron is more infectious and
way less deadly apparently alrighty in
just one second we'll get to more
measures that the left is pushing that
have no relation to the data which means
they have to there's an agenda behind it
if you're if you see somebody doing
something and you're like they're saying
it's for this reason but it clearly is
not that reason there has to be another
reason they're doing it and the reason
is because of the control they want the
control over your life they want to they
want
they want to portray themselves as
capable of doing a thing they are not
capable of doing we'll get to more in
just one second first
you may be far from ordinary but the
truth is that erectile dysfunction is
actually shockingly common in fact 52 of
guys aged 40 to 70 will experience some
form of erectile dysfunction so why live
with that why not just go get it solved
head on over to getroman.com ben right
now speak to a us licensed health care
professional about erectile dysfunction
get 15 bucks off your first month of
treatment roman ready it's confidence
personified it means that things are
going to work the way they are supposed
to and roman system is completely
confidential totally discreet no logos
no labels on the packages with roman get
a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for erectile dysfunction all from
the comfort and privacy of your home a
us licensed healthcare professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if medication is appropriate it'll
ship to you free with two day shipping
the whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet getting started
is simple just go to getroman.com bend
complete and online visit today take
care of your ed without leaving your
home complete that online visit today
connect with a us licensed healthcare
professional and get it taken care of
today go to getroman.com today if you're
prescribed get 15 bucks off your first
month of ed treatment make sure you're
ready to have confidence in control of
this season roman ready alrighty we'll
get to more on this in just one moment
because again
everybody is rushing to the cameras in
the microphones to announce policies
that make no sense there is an agenda
that agenda is um
i think being revealed by a certain
number of hard leftists first as you
know and as i've mentioned you need to
go sign our petition right now
dailywire.com do not comply this is our
petition against the biden vax mandates
we have over 900 000 signatures thus far
we are trying to get to a million before
christmas please sign the petition right
now forward it to all your friends and
make the magic happen also i have to
announce something super duper exciting
okay this is a brand new series it's
titled the search it's completely
different than anything i've ever done
instead of me just interviewing somebody
in sort of probing fashion which is what
you'll get on the sunday special it's
something different it's how i actually
talk with my friends who happen to be
some of the most famous and influential
people on earth right but it's how we
talk when we're usually not on camera
it's a voyeuristic view of the
conversations with my closest and most
influential friends my good friend
jordan peterson is the very first to
join me so jordan and i whenever we talk
it's it's always fun we talk about
family and we talk about life when we
talk about meaning and it's kind of a
different tone and tenor than what you
would normally get in an interview with
jordan or jordan interviews me it's a
different kind of conversation we went
to a coffee shop and we just chatted
and it's great it's as if you are a fly
on the wall when i hang out with jordan
the conversation with jordan drops
tonight dailywire.com if you're not a
member yet now is the best time to sign
up head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe sign up today these are great
conversations i think intimate
conversations conversations where
we're having mental and spiritual
connections with people it's great
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so everybody is talking about
lockdowns and vaccine boosters and
universal masking okay i have a staff
from south africa okay this one's just
breaking you ready
the south african hospitalization rate
which is what you care about
is at 1.7 percent
by comparison by comparison during their
last wave of delta
the hospitalization rate was 19
that's how much less deadly omicron is
than delta
it is it is literally by the statistics
about
10 times
less deadly than delta
and and yet
what are you talking about what what are
you
none of this makes any sense and yet you
have the nfl has announced a return to
universal masking
and other protocols amid covid19
outbreak the nfl said throughout the
pandemic we have continuously evolved
our protocols to meet our goal of
advancing the safety of the players
coaches and staff the changes we are
making today aim to address the
increasing cases and the advent of the
micron variant
they say effective immediately all clubs
will implement preventative measures
that have proven effective
really have they proven effective
have they though masking regardless of
vaccination status has that been like
super duper duper pooper effective
against omicron because i missed the
data they say it's been proven effective
i'd like some proof some proof would be
excellent
remote or outdoor meetings eliminating
in-person meals no outside visitors
while on team travel we will continue to
strongly encourage boosters as the most
effective protection for young adult
healthy males like the most healthy
human beings in our society
finally based on expert advice we will
adjust to the return to participation
requirements for those who have
recovered from covet 19.
this is all insanity and again they're
just gonna keep pushing it so you got
espn's jeff van gundy saying the nba is
gonna have to pause or bubble these are
the healthiest human beings on planet
earth and they're gonna have to bubble
or pause because people are getting mild
colds in south
africa mike it's all sports i i really
feel
that at some point there's going to be a
pause to our season a bubble to our
season
the way they're predicting these cases
to continue to go as davis with the dump
i don't see any way around it well
clearly we hope that you're wrong but
it's impossible to predict
um no it isn't tough to predict if
you're not if you're not
invested in the narrative what is the
end goal here well for the far left the
end goal as always is transformational
change there's an article by anna north
in vox.com today talking about work here
is the title of the piece the world as
we know it is ending
why are we still at work
from the pandemic to climate change
americans are still expected to work no
matter what happens the entire
contention of the article is that
because of kovid no one should ever go
to work again because work is bad
instead we need to make sure that people
never have to work again we have to
restructure the entire american economy
around the idea that people should do
less work because work is bad
work is bad and now so question who's
going to support all the people who are
sitting in their homes because they're
afraid of covid which is not going to
kill them if it's omicron and if they
are not
ridden with cancer for example
what is it there is no data but
transformational change always requires
a hook for the left covid was the best
hook they've ever seen and they will not
let it go ever ever for the rest of time
ever it's up to you to push them it's up
to you to push back it's up to you to
say i'm not going to comply with your
nonsense because you're not even
presenting me with the data this is why
again i'll urge people head on over to
dailywire.com slash do not comply sign
our petition we're at 900 000 signatures
we're trying to get to a million
but
as a as a basic way of living they are
offering you no life in return for
no real additional shot that you're
going to avoid covid
if that sounds like a great bargain to
you keep voting for him all right we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show drew
shows every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you tonight he's
diving into how democrats fear the right
are the ones threatening democracy so
head on over to dailywire.com 7 pm
eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin